you guys should be home
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream 1
40 140 140. here we are amazing
um so
uh here is the long and and short
um we have just moved
now much more next week yeah
substantially we'll talk more about that
but at the moment what there is to say
is the good news is we've moved so we
have all the equipment we need right
here the bad news is we don't know where
it is and so the technical difficulties
in this episode are liable to be
noticeable we apologize for that we hope
you'll bear with us
um
uh in any case we will correct this as
quickly as possible as the uh the bins
and cardboard boxes disappear from our
lives and the objects return
all right so with that said
uh do you want to
set us in motion yeah so uh we will talk
more next week about what what is
happening in our world today it's gonna
be we're gonna have a short episode
today and we're not going to have a q a
for a number of technical and other
reasons
um however we are going to end this live
stream with a question that had already
come in from from the people at our
wonderful discord server this week every
week we invite them to vote on a
question that they most want us to
answer and uh
and because we
admire them and uh had to make a last
minute change we are going to finish off
with their question this week in the
main in the main episode and we will be
back next week probably again without a
q a but at some point soon things are
going to get back in
in uh
in line in sync and all those things but
i wanted to point something out yes
actually we are doing a q a and usually
we do a q's and a's ah see we got a q a
yeah it's not a separate stream though
is it no no no it's uh it's going to be
on the tail end of this one just you
know to keep things compact indeed
indeed
okay uh is odyssey working zack
okay so there's chat live on odyssey if
you're if you're watching live uh cool
you can go over there and join the chat
and uh if not you will be able to find
us you know soon after this is we're
done here
uh everywhere you can only find podcasts
including spotify with the video
and uh just you know all the usual stuff
consider checking out our book hunter
gatherers guide to 21st century natural
selections which is my sub stack
where i will be posting more uh on this
tuesday
and we are supported by our audience
that's you we appreciate you subscribing
liking sharing with our full episodes
here on youtube and odyssey and our
clips at dark course podcast clips
and uh you know our regular viewers know
this already but we were demonetized by
youtube good 14 months ago at this point
for saying things uh many of which they
have since come around on but have not
acknowledged that we were right and they
were wrong and have not re-monetized us
although many of you have noticed that
there are ads youtube ads showing up on
our videos which means that someone is
profiting from our work but it's not us
so we encourage you sharing liking
talking about what you are hearing here
and if you have the capacity and the
interest in doing so we of course are
appreciative of uh any financial support
you can give us you can join us at one
of our patreons we had our private q a
on my patreon last week always a lot of
fun
and
you can also join bret at his patreon
where he does
monthly conversations
at some of the higher tiers
the
the first of this month being tomorrow i
believe
at 9 00 a.m pacific and of course either
of our patrons you can join us uh join
the discord server
where uh there are honest conversations
about difficult topics
they have an actual camping trip meetup
scheduled in the next couple of weeks
and
um excuse me
all the demographics that you might
imagine are represented there and you
are at no risk of being canceled for uh
not agreeing with uh with what others
think so there it is
of course we also have sponsors so
before we launch into the main part of
the podcast let us embark on sponsors
apologies our printer is uh hidden away
from us somewhere we don't know where at
the moment uh so we're gonna be reading
these from my screen here because we
don't know where we don't know if it
printed the documents that we sent to it
oh it might there might be there might
be papers spewing into a box right now
yes yeah absolutely yeah that's not how
it works but yeah that's a sort of an
amusing we don't know that that's not
how it works at this point there was a
point earlier in our lives when that was
not how it worked it's easier to assess
how things don't work actually well and
there's more to talk about on that yes
yes
rather a lot more um okay so our
sponsors this week are eight sleep ned
and public goods and without further ado
we're going to launch into those
all right i ate sleep i have to find on
my computer here yes i thought that was
going to be easy but no
here we go
our first sponsor this week is eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod helps you get good
sleep
as we discuss in the sleep chapter of
our book hunter others guides the 21st
century intelligent life that found its
way to earth might be surprised by a lot
of what it found on our planet but not
by the fact of sleep or of dreams sleep
is necessary without good sleep we are
destined to be unhealthy unproductive
consistent good sleep can help reduce
the likelihood of serious health issues
decrease the risk of heart disease lower
blood pressure and even reduce the risk
of alzheimer's
and eight sleep is really a fantastic
product we really enjoy this a lot
despite how valuable and necessary sleep
is more than 30 of americans struggle
with sleep and frankly i think that
number is low
temperature is one of the main reasons
that people often report not being able
to sleep well it is well known that
individuals and couples for instance who
sleep together often have different
optimal sleep temperatures
brett
eat sleep allows fine-tuned temperature
regulation for both people having a cool
warm cool room and a warm bed just my
preference is a luxury that eight sleep
makes easy to obtain and if you
uh perhaps prefer having a really really
cold bed you can also get that with
eight sleep the pod pro cover by eight
sleep is the only sleep technology that
dynamically cools and heats each side of
the bed to maintain the optimal or just
preferred sleeping temperature for what
your body needs with the pod you can
start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
fahrenheit and neither of us neither of
us want either of those extremes if
you're cooking that would be appropriate
if you're
cooking in your dreams if you want to
just be able to roll over and eat your
eggs right then
that's the way it's not not recommended
that's i don't think it's rated for that
the temperature of the cover will adjust
each side of the bed based on your sleep
stages biometrics and bedroom
temperature reacting dynamically to
create the optimal sleeping environment
and that sounds that sounds like science
fiction but it really it really works
it's amazing eight sleep users fall
asleep up to 32 faster reduce sleep
interruptions by 40
and get more restful sleep overall and
with 30 more deep sleep on average that
restorative sleep will likely help with
physical recovery hormone regulation and
mental clarity
and they also have an alarm feature
which can wake you with temperature
change and also slight chest level
vibrations which is so much gentler than
any standard alarm than an audio alarm
we are both a little skeptical of 8
sleep but are now completely sold we are
surprised at how much we truly
appreciate this bed and they will sell
you a mattress with the pod cover or
just the pod cover so you can adopt any
mattress that you already like already
have
to the eight sleep in sleep mode
go to eightsleep.com darkhorse for
exclusive labor day savings through
september 11th eight sleep currently
ships within the us canada the uk select
coaches in the eu and australia so again
that's eat sleep.com darkhorse for
exclusive labor day savings through
september 11th
okay that's eight sleep our second
sponsor
again nothing is printed so this is all
a little bit kludgy apologies is ned
ned is a cbd company that stands out in
a highly saturated cbd market ned was
started by two friends who discovered
that their hyper-modern lives were
leaving them feeling empty bewildered
and disconnected something about this
way of life they say on their website
just wasn't working so they started ned
you can buy cbd products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but nets
blends stand out i am particularly fond
of their de-stress blend now its
de-stress blend is a one-to-one formula
of cbd and cbg made from the world's
purest full spectrum hemp and also
features a botanical infusion of
ashwagandha cardamom and cinnamon cbg is
known as the mother of all cannabinoids
because of how effective it is at
combining anxiety
no
cbg is known as the mother of all
cannabinoids because of how effective it
is at combating
combating anxiety and stress by
inhibiting the reuptake of gaba which is
the neurotransmitter responsible for
stress regulation this combination
leaves me feeling a bit easier with
whatever comes my way
many of the cbd companies out there
source their hemp from industrial firms
in china but just like with low quality
alcohol low quality cbd can have
undesired effects that is usda certified
organic all of ned's full spectrum hemp
oil is extracted from usda certified
organic hemp plants grown by an
independent farmer named jonathan in
peonia colorado at some point jonathan
is going to have more work than he can
handle
also ned shares third party lab reports
and information about who farms their
products and their extraction process on
their site these products are
science-backed nature-based solutions
that offer an alternative to
prescription and over-the-counter drugs
they are chock full of premium cbd and a
full spectrum of active cannabinoids
terpenes flavonoids and trichomes ned's
full spectrum hemp oil nourishes the
body's endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance if you'd like
to give net a try dark horse listeners
get 15 off net products with code dark
horse visit
helloned.com darkhorse to get access
that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d dot com slash dark horse
to get 15 off thank you ned for
sponsoring the show and offering our
listeners a natural remedy for some of
life's most common health
issues and our final
sponsor
this week is public goods public goods
public goods is a one-stop shop for
everyday essentials their ingredients
are carefully sourced high quality and
affordable
you can simplify your life by getting
your necessities at public goods public
goods has coffee and tea grains and oils
like olive and avocado they've got
castile soap and trash bags and laundry
detergent they have spices and extracts
vinegars and hot sauces dishware and
glassware there's everything you need at
public goods to make a meal including
the materials to serve it on public
goods searches the globe to find clean
healthy eco-friendly innovative products
public goods cares about health and
sustainability their products are free
of harmful ingredients and additives and
the ingredients are ethically sourced
rather than buying from a bunch of
single product brands public goods
members can buy all of their premium
essentials in one place with one
beautiful simple streamlined aesthetic
and their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place it
really is an everything store
for dark horse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again but they are
giving you fifteen dollars to spend on
your first purchase go to
publicgoods.com darkhorse or use the
code darkhorse at checkout that is p u b
l i c g o o d s dot com
slash dark horse to receive 15 off your
first order
all right
that's our sponsors for this week again
uh we only take sponsorship from
from companies who make products or
offer services that we really stand
behind so eight sleep net and public
goods we appreciate you and we
appreciate that you are uh sponsoring
this podcast
all right
without further ado without further ado
here we are um
without much a deal
about
anything at all right exactly yeah
i wonder how many titles he went through
or if it was even he i've
i've recently stumbled into the quadrant
of the internet where people debate
these things and i hate to say it but
the skeptics have uh more
their arguments are stronger than i was
expecting so which if we aren't prepared
for this conversation at all but we are
not uh
are you
the the quadrant that you stumbled into
was it the
he was a he but he wasn't the he we
think he was or was it he was a she or
is it he was a conglomerate um there are
several
credible theories the basic theories are
they uh
good point not theories hypotheses i
don't know what's gotten into me
probably a lack of sleep is there's no
net i think
indeed
no so there are apparently schools of
thought and the central premise on which
the skeptic community seems to all agree
is that the guy whose name wasn't
exactly shakespeare but was close
couldn't possibly have written them
based on who he was and what he would
have known and whether he was even
literate
and then the question is well who did
write them and there are apparently a
couple different schools of thought uh
whether it was uh
this guy at oxford whose name escapes me
or whether it was uh francis bacon
apparently as a contender
but let's just say
you don't want to delve into this unless
you're ready to entertain
the possibility that uh much of what you
learned in school just ain't right yeah
well i mean so we
yeah i i have i have delved briefly a
long time ago back when it was like oh
maybe he was a woman like really
okay
um
but it when you raised this issue with
me i don't know a few months ago because
you would fall into this particular hole
you found yourself trapped like a bear
trap at the bottom of it like i can't
get i never wanted this i can't get out
uh i said to you you know of all of the
things of all of the things that we were
told were certain that we were taught as
if this like you don't have to question
this one at all
from school the idea that maybe william
shakespeare isn't who we thought he was
or he didn't write the stuff
that that's like really low in the list
of things that would plague me like
that's okay right no if if that turns
out to be okay
right what difference does it make it's
you know what does it make well i mean
the problem is it does make a difference
um
just i mean to some questions here let
me let me just be completely transparent
about this i fell into this rabbit hole
i returned to this rabbit hole recently
when
is right exactly um i did encounter this
from the somebody
an essay by curtis yarvin who is
obviously a very controversial figure
this is a topic on which he actually
does have a kind of a political slant on
it but um
but anyway i thought his argument was
pretty compelling and it came from the
place that i
i most appreciate which is
he
uh
was ready to just dismiss this nonsense
until he started delving and it was like
oh geez this is more credible than i
thought and so he lays out
the case for one of the
one of the schools of thought
and he explains why it would make a lot
of sense and why it would make a lot of
sense of things in shakespeare which is
why it matters right it doesn't really
matter if some person you don't know
wasn't the actual person but it was
another person right who who had a
perspective that we now impose
different things onto because of our
sense of who shakespeare was and so i
think it is
it is very important from the
perspective of understanding the content
of shakespeare it is not very important
from the perspective of somebody
uh you know who
our only familiarity is through his work
and the study of it and if it was
actually somebody else
who we are only familiar with through
the study of uh their work you know okay
it's an interesting fact but it's not
and and for those of us who read some
shakespeare uh like you know i was a
literature major for a couple of years
you know who really read some
shakespeare and who admired it and who
thought about it and we've gone to a
number of
plays put on by the wonderful oregon
shakespeare company down in ashland
mostly although i also my parents lived
in london we went to the globe a few
times and saw a number of particular
place there
um
even with that level of sort of passing
literate familiarity
i'm not a historian so i don't know who
else's historical record will be changed
by the fact that they might have been
doing all the writing
and
so that that's what i meant by who cares
like some people will care for sure uh
but in terms of oh my god this destroys
everything like nope the work is still
the work i mean maybe maybe for me this
gets down to that question and this was
actually something that was a lot very
live
very live argument in literature circles
back when i was studying literature in
school which was do you take the work of
art at on its face
or do you need to incorporate into an
understanding of the moment in time the
personality and biography and like
developmental trajectory and and and you
know wealth and other demographics of
the person who created the art
and you know frankly i can see an
argument for either and at least in the
late 80s early 90s when i was engaged in
these sorts of um when i was forced into
these sorts of conversations in college
classrooms
it seemed like you had to take one or
the other of these positions and
uh in terms of if you're if you are in
any way interested compelled by the idea
that an art a piece of art a work of art
once made should be able to stand on its
own
then the questions about who shakespeare
might actually be
while potentially interesting while
potentially bearing some impact on how
other people might interpret it uh can
be relegated to a different conversation
you can still assess what you do about
nothing for instance which is how we got
here um on its own recognizance here is
why you are a hundred percent slightly
wrong a hundred percent 100 slightly
wrong i don't know what that means it
doesn't mean a damn thing i just you're
obviously mostly right but uh before you
say this yes i will say that there is
one thing that i really like about this
temporary setup that we've got going
here
which is that while it's a little harder
for us to look at one another
i can make on eye contact with our
producer who is also our 18 year old son
and we can roll our eyes at each other
when you say things like that right i
prefer to bulge my eyes at him if there
are
things that require that communication
but in any case um but in the door in
the in the old studio uh you couldn't do
we couldn't see him here is why you are
100 slightly wrong
um
were it bacon
wore it bacon yeah not uh kevin or
or delicious sizzling i mean actually if
you were in your house for hours after
if it were kevin bacon that would be
even more interesting although kevin
bacon is less interesting because it
would imply time travel and that would
be important potentially but i digress
this has nothing to do with why i'm 100
slightly wrong this is not has nothing
to do with why you're 100 slightly wrong
you're 100 slightly wrong because were
it bacon
then the question is
why is this already transcendent figure
transcendent in a second modality and i
believe that this you and i spent a year
working on the question of how to build
a school to generate hyper competence
right the kind of hyper competence we
occasionally see in the world and i
would argue that somebody like davinci
for example
hyper competent and the point is i
personally i don't believe that has
anything to do could not logically be
the result of unusual genes what that is
is some sort of unusual trajectory that
has caused the right set of skills to
accumulate in the right way so that you
get the synergies and if bacon is a
second example of this then the point is
well we there's nothing more important
than figuring out what that
juxtaposition of capacities is and where
it comes from because if you can produce
it for people young enough to get the
benefit
the point is we could have more such
hyper competent people and there's
nothing that could be more important
than that i absolutely agree with that
but i don't i don't think that that
is a rejoinder to what i said with
regard to
you know
the works of art themselves the works
themselves can they be assessed on their
own and their own recognizance that's
what i said and if i say that if i
continue to say that i will start to
wonder what exactly recognizes yeah it's
not it's not recognizes on their own
merits on their own merits there it is
um on their own merits
that's a separate question from
oh my god these works of art that have
tremendous merit were also produced by
someone who framed an understanding of
modern science
well yes and no
i do think that
let's say for example it was bacon
then
it imposes it necessarily imposes a kind
of depth on
the
social implications of shakespeare right
the very deep
comprehension in the works in the works
themselves right for somebody who uh
you know is as logically rigorous as
bacon
to find himself as socially uh deep and
insightful as shakespeare
would i think have an implication it
wouldn't be part of every conversation
about the works of shakespeare but i
just
for me and you know maybe i'm a
you know a guy interested in things and
i find
you know the idea of a guy interested in
things also socially that insightful um
it's too important a a connection
uh for me to view them as distinct well
i mean this this this is an interesting
conversation cause i do i do feel a
little bit like i'm back in a better
version of my freshman year literature
classes
where
you know the rejoinder and i don't i
don't know that i'm playing devil's
advocate here
exactly but maybe i am the rejoinder
from those who would say you know what
you like the art is the art once created
it
it it loses it loses its tether to the
creator
who who made it and it needs to be able
to be assessed on its own that doesn't
mean that it is best assessed on its own
that doesn't mean that you wouldn't
learn more perhaps about
either the create the its creator or
maybe even to some degree what's in it
uh by comparing it to the other things
that the person who made the piece of
art made
but the the art itself the sonnet the
play whatever
uh should you know it either it either
is worthy of having been remembered for
i mean what how old is shakespeare 600
years 500 years
i am embarrassed i don't remember
exactly when shakespeare was uh you know
it's
there is
presumably
a reason inherent to the words that he
wrote
that
we have and continue to learn from and
reflect on those words today
that
while
we could take that in a different
direction we could expand on it if we
have additional context that no one you
know that was lost to history for many
hundreds of years with a revelation
about shakespeare's identity
that doesn't change the actual work of
art
um
i'm going to disagree with you
and i'm going to argue that
this is about to become very clear so in
my opinion i certainly understand the
argument that the art should stand
independently of the artist and i i like
it i just don't believe it for the
following reason
the is possible let's take music for
example
it is possible to generate through a
formulaic approach to music
things that are irresistible they may
not be good
but they're irresistible um you know pop
music
can be done by somebody who
understands the tropes and the chord
progressions and you can put together
something that
you can discover a recipe and repeat the
recipe over and over again yes have had
maybe one original insight or or
source of creativity or or
borrowed it yeah and uh and just know
know how to make uh variations on a
theme you can do without being
innovative and they can be um
so catchy you know the song that gets in
your mind and you just wish it would go
away because it's not even good you
don't like it but you can't make it go
away
um that is a possibility in music and so
what i would argue is you know like as
we argue in the book
we're watching the junkification of all
sorts of important things right from
food to sex to friendship all these
things are being reduced to a a terrible
version of these a low quality low depth
version and
the problem is
i would argue that you should be very
cautious about what music you let into
your mind because it's so potent
right music is so potent it's selling an
idea of
convincing you of things that may or may
not be true and that really in part
you know when i listen to for example
say arctic monkeys okay arctic monkeys
if you listen across many songs you get
a sense for
their moral position right their
intellectual position
and when they then take
a when they take an approach that is
surprising
right you can hear what it must mean in
what context it exists but that's a
different argument that's a does a
single example of a creator's art
uh
fully represent what they can do versus
assessing their entire
right so you know
that's quite different you haven't said
anything to me nor do i know anything
about it i couldn't even name or tell
you how many people are in the arctic
monkeys i couldn't either right so i i
think that actually
does not i don't know that it doesn't
counter your point but it doesn't
support your point well i think it's i
think it supports it in a sense because
if it is true that the art ought to
stand on its own then each of the pieces
probably ought to stand on their own too
and they don't that's my point is that
the context of this no no no that's so
that that claim that you just made
suggests that
an artist a creator
needs to have every single thing that
they put out into the world be excellent
no that no no not at all not at all all
i'm saying is that when you allow music
into your mind
you want to be cautious about it and
over time you might develop trust for an
artist who has
brought you insights that stand up right
music that doesn't turn you know tinny
and awful after the fourth listening
right so you're extending a kind of
trust and my point is that that trust as
the ice gets thicker the willingness to
entertain things that that artist
delivers should go up right at least
it's my experience that it does go up as
somebody produces high quality stuff i'm
willing to you know
to give them more more rope effectively
but
but that has to do with it being created
by the same person without requiring any
knowledge about who that person is i
agree i agree i really think it's a
different argument
it's not wholly different because you
you can learn about
um you can learn about who the people
are by virtue of their product and i
suppose if we had no idea who
shakespeare was you know we just didn't
know we you know we found all of the
documents with no understanding of where
they came from then you could infer
something about the person and in fact
that would be a good exercise what how
does shakespeare look different if you
don't start from an understanding of who
the author was supposed to be if you
started from here's the sum total of
everything we know that they produced
now who are they right then the question
is well actually which kind of person
does it point to does it point to oxford
does it point to bacon does it
and yeah that that is at least how i
was exposed to shakespeare right now i i
suspect that that's true for most people
you know you don't start with like first
we're going to talk about this guy
and the fact that he created a bunch of
stuff and then we're going to throw you
into some place like no here's hamlet
read it oh god really that's hard i'm
only in 8th grade how am i supposed to
get through that you know like what you
know it happens in a way that i don't
think is terrific often um you know some
people have reported learning you know
being exposed to shakespeare in a really
brilliant way usually probably by
actually going to the theater and you
know actually seeing it as opposed to
reading the words in the sort of dead
form on the page
um but again
you know saying oh if you know if you
like that thing by him you're probably
gonna like this thing by him is not the
same thing as saying oh you need to know
something about the man who created it
in order to appreciate it it's really
quite different like recognizing that
there is an identity be that there is an
artist there is a creator
and that that creator made these things
over here a through d and didn't do
these things over here e through h
is quite different from saying you need
to know a lot of things that are true
about that person and then inform your
appreciation of his art with the other
things that you know to be true that's a
very different argument well what do we
do though with joseph heller for example
what do we do with joseph yeah what do
we do with joseph so i will say as you
start like i don't um
the only thing i know about joseph
heller is that while i'm sure he wrote
many things he's famous for one long
piece of of narrative fiction right but
you know
forget the other works my feeling is he
wrote a transcendent work and i'm i
haven't read anything else by him i
don't know if they're underrated or
overrated or he really wrote one great
thing my feeling is you write one thing
as good as catch 22 and you've
contributed so much more than the
average person contributes to humanity
that you know
you've done your part anything else you
do is gravy right but my basic question
was
the fact that joseph heller
went to war and then wrote the
dark satire about
war that he wrote
places it in a very different context if
he was a piece nick as you read catch 22
i'm trying to so i've read it a few
times i'm trying to remember the first
time i read it
did i know as i read it
was he
does he know war does the author hear no
war
and i think i think that there are some
and you know this is going to be
different for like 2d or 3d or you know
many musical artists musicians as well
but for authors for for artists of
letters
uh
there will often be a question
especially for
authors of fiction and poetry right
what
where from does this insight come
is this
abstract is this academic knowledge or
was this man in the trenches rise of
heller yeah right and i
certainly i mean you know what do we do
with him i don't i don't i don't think
there's anything we need to do with him
per se but you can
you can find that
that book transcendent and yet i don't
know if there's anyone who's ever read
it and not if they didn't know at the
beginning at some point while reading it
be driven to discover
on their own you know did this man go to
war yeah
um
that's true
i think also michael lewis if we think
about what he has contributed uh liars
poker uh
i haven't read any of his stuff so i
can't say as much about him um
and you're now causing me to doubt that
i have the right
i think i do i think that's right i just
haven't but in any case the what he
reports
you know in the same way that joseph
heller tells us something incredibly
alarming about
bureaucracy in the context of life and
death
right
um lewis tells us something shocking
about the games that are played
economically in and around everything we
care about in other words if you
if you did not if he had not seen it on
the inside or you didn't know who wrote
this and it could be made up
the point is
how plausible is this
much less plausible it's shocking it's
maybe beyond the pale
if it's written by somebody who wouldn't
know because they've never been in the
game
but when it's written by somebody who
was in the game and the point is oh my
god does this explain
what we see
and
um so anyway i all i'm arguing is that
there is a there's a particular type of
fiction
i think that you have identified two
examples of with liars poker and with
coach 22
wherein
uh the suspension of disbelief
and maybe that's not quite the right
phrase but
the reader
need not suspend as much disbelief if
they do have on board an understanding
of actually the author here knows where
if he speaks yeah
yeah that's that's that's basically the
argument and you know again
i'm not arguing
i would like art that stands on its own
in fact maybe you can argue that uh the
question is how close have you gotten to
that
right when you've written something that
is that the versamilitude is so
uh
so good
that it stands on its own because people
will infer that you must know what
you're talking about
um then then that's the ideal on the
other hand maybe the problem is some
things are so remote from our experience
or you know from the experience of
normal people living normal lives that
you would maybe never interpret the
uh the kind of ruthlessness that happens
when life and death decisions are made
in a board room
uh unless somebody who had seen it had
decided to reveal that through
something artistic
you know there's a
what occurs to me
is there's there's a modern case
that
excuse me
that we hear about a lot
uh from the activists who
land on the opposite opposite conclusion
as as i will hear
and
it's jk rowling
right so uh you know jk rowling's origin
story by the time i you know we actually
weren't reading them as they were coming
out even though we were adults by then
and we had friends who were saying oh my
god the harry potter books are
extraordinary um but we read them to our
our boys when they were young some
number of years later and i've actually
gone back and read them and you know
we've watched the movies and they're
they're brilliant she's she's
extraordinary she's created not just a
universe but uh
but
a suite of characters and uh insights
into the human condition she's created
she has revealed insights into human
condition
uh that are truly powerful
and
at the point
that she has long past that and she is
now often writing under a pen name and
uh and
yes you know by
book three or four probably we knew that
actually she wrote the first book as a
single mother on the dole i think
whatever it's called in the uk
and uh that she was doing this you know
in her off in her spare moments
uh while trying to support her her child
feels like it just you know it just it
sort of elevates our sense of oh she you
know she really had it in her she had
this book in her and then it turns out
she had all these other books in her but
that isn't that relevant honestly that
that speaks to her tenacity and that
speaks to her
i guess her tenacity really but the
thing that comes out more recently
uh that she's standing up for the truly
obvious conclusion that women are women
and men aren't
and that this has enraged an army of
activist online trolls
for want of a better description
who proclaim with tears and their
i don't even know i'm just going to say
like pink hair i don't even know um
probably eyes though i was going to say
eyes like how what do they do to their
eyes i don't think they can do anything
to their eyes yet we're not they can
have their pink hair blocking them their
pink hair obscured eyes i probably got
it like a maybe a unicorn i don't even
know um but you know people who are pro
who are saying ah i you know i grew up
with you you were you know the harry
potter universe was the thing that meant
everything to me and now i know that the
creator is a turf
and
a trans exclusionary radical feminist
and how could you how you know how how
dare you jk rowling
destroy the harry potter universe
for me by
saying that women are women yeah i mean
the number of of twists of logic and
there are just failures of logic is
extraordinary
but
i think i maybe wouldn't have even
thought
to attribute her connection to reality
to my appreciation of the books but for
the
sturm and drawing of the activists
but the more the more tearful and
fretful and anxiety laden they get over
the fact that the author of this amazing
series isn't what they thought she was
somehow or what they assumed she was the
more i think actually
that fits of course jk rally knows what
reality is
how else could she have written such a
fantastical and yet true to humanity
universe yeah how could you reveal
things about reality in a
fictional a highly fictional universe in
which the rules don't even uh the the
natural rules of the real universe don't
apply right that takes it takes real
skill and insight yeah i will point out
that uh you said that she's a turf
that's
only
halfway there because she's also a star
she's an asphalter an astral turf yeah
um
but i i love this point you're making
are you happy with yourself
sorry you know moderately but
i i love i love the point that you're
making it is the it is the counterpoint
to uh
to the one that i'm making naturally
which is
um
[Music]
if
it is true
that the
um
that the context of the person and the
life that they led is relevant to
interpreting
the
work in many cases or at least in some
cases i think we've established
it is not true that at the point that
you discover that somebody who has
written something truly marvelous has
some belief that you're politically not
lined up with that it invalidates the
work that they've done in fact in fact
you are you know that you're at odds
with yourself what you should really be
saying is how interesting that somebody
whose work i value has this very
different belief from me on this topic
which doesn't make them right and me
wrong but it certainly means that i need
to i need to listen carefully and figure
out why i disagree with this person and
what the implications are
and this so what i was going to ask you
earlier too was okay if you think it's
necessary or it's it's almost always
valuable
to know something about basically the
personal
background of the creator of works of
art
do you feel the same way about works of
science
um
and before you answer that what you just
reminded me of was you know let's think
about the early 20th century and how
many powerful figures in both in both
science and art turn out to have been
anti-semitic fascists actually yeah
right like you know we we have like
wagner over in music
and
um boy i'm forgetting all of the
you know the scientists with truly
horrible beliefs who contributed greatly
to to science yeah fisher fisher good
okay so let's just go with like wagner
and and ronald fisher and ri fisher um
in art and science respectively who
contributed you know beauty and truth to
our world lindbergh um different
different artists or scientists but like
there are a lot of these yeah and you
know do
what what do we make
of the contributions and you know
wagner's a little bit tough because
neither you were i are you know
you know opera fans or you know wagner
fans exactly um but
you know so much in evolutionary biology
and statistics relies
is built on the fundamentals that fish
are either revealed or or
or came to understand a new form and
shared with the world
and you you don't want to overthrow that
because the guy was
personally kind of awful but okay there
is a limit and i will point out where i
think it is
it's a little hard to you know to defend
the exact limit but i think the question
you just asked is one i mean
because we've surfaced it as a question
we now have to address it in a way that
would have been totally intuitive to us
10 years ago is still intuitive to us
but it's becoming less obvious in the
world which is that the question be the
question being
if you think that it's almost always
valuable to know something about the
personality of the creative or work of
art do you feel the same way about
knowing something about the personality
of the creative work of science is that
the question yeah okay now
um
what i would say is you deal with this
you do not
decide to elevate the quality of the
work based on the personal qualities
except in that they are directly
relevant and you do not
denigrate the work
because the person had defects even
though some of those defects are
you know
scandalous right the work is the work
and i think this is a place where i
treat art a little bit more like science
and um
and and you you hold them a little bit
farther apart and say you know are you
know art isn't science why why should we
pretend that it is but you know look
let's take the fisher example okay okay
here's the thing
first of all i should tell you when i
you you will remember when i took my
prelims as a graduate student
um i
uh
ran into trouble i nearly failed them
because i didn't know some things that
my elders were certain i should know
and they were things that they weren't
holding other people responsible for
knowing so i felt badly treated
but i was not badly treated what i
learned later was what they were telling
me was look bret the stuff that you want
to do
requires you to be intimately familiar
with these things that you don't know
they give you a personal they gave as
they should have given all of us and i
think to some degree they did
but seeing that you had particular
interest in an insight in a number of
theoretical areas
they were holding you to the standard of
if you're going to do that you're going
to know this first right well and they
were careful about it because the thing
is a lot of what i was doing was like
look the people who have done the
supposedly
foundational work here didn't do it
right so it's you know so it's a waste
of time to follow it up and their point
was yeah but these people know
you you have to check these people out
because they're actually the stuff
you're building on and because they're
you know two generations back you
you're missing them because they're not
in the conversation
so anyway i did go back and i learned
about uh soul right and haldane and
fisher and the thing about fisher fisher
became very important to me because when
i was working in panama
i was working on bats but as you know i
was working my sort of side hustle
was a theoretical
paper on
why species diversity goes up as you get
towards the equator and there was a um
a
side hustle yeah it was my intellectual
side hustle um but anyway i got into a
discussion
why am i uh blanking on his name the
scientist who lived on bci um
i'll come up with it at some point here
but anyway there was a very
bright
eggbert lee edward lee was a very bright
autistic scientist who had an insight an
encyclopedic knowledge of ecology as it
was understood at the time he lived on
the island he also had a place in gamboa
but he lived on the island and if he
he would invite people who were also
living on the island for a time to come
have a drink with him in the evening
and then he would talk to him about your
interest and if he found you
that if he found
you interesting enough to have
conversations with he would invite you
back so anyway i learned a lot from him
about ecology that i needed to know from
my side hustle project
and one of the things that he pointed me
to
was ronald fisher's work
on ecology which didn't answer the
question
but it was necessary for what i was
doing so i be i became i really began to
appreciate fisher as an ecologist
um the whole time i knew
that he had these
abhorrent anti-semitic beliefs and you
know not only are they abhorrent but i'm
jewish right
but it didn't change
what he understood about you know the
way creatures interact in the forest
right it was an additional piece of
context what what's more
it
just simply it re it emphasizes the fact
that if you have the sense that there
are good people and there are bad people
and the good people are not only morally
good but they're also then destined to
be intellectually tops right you're just
going to be confused because the fact is
all of us are mixed bags
and
the activists see binaries where there
aren't any and they fail to see binaries
obviously exists very well said
um so anyway my feeling is what do you
do with a guy like fisher who is
anti-semitic and uh
brilliant in multiple places uh in
biology and mathematics right right well
you do exactly that he was brilliant in
multiple places in biology and
mathematics and he had major personality
defects and what's more his biology
wasn't perfect as i mentioned i think
in a recent
conversation may have been the private q
a um his work
fischer's runaway sexual selection work
i think is nonsense um and you know so
the fact that his other work in biology
is so important to me doesn't make that
work better than it was and that doesn't
make it useless i mean you and i felt a
little bit differently in terms of how
we view it but regardless regardless if
even if you land where you do you know
it's nonsense uh
you you won't doubt that it has spurred
a great many conversations and useful uh
contributions downstream of it no in
fact it was useful to me figuring out
you know this on paper this makes sense
but there's something bugging me about
it right that you know
probably
dozens or a hundred hours spent thinking
about why does this not sit right with
me
you know maybe i wouldn't understand
what i think i understand if i hadn't
you know had that frustrating piece of
work in front of me so anyway
why is this even a tough question what
do you do with somebody who's not
perfect uh file them with the rest of
the not perfect people and you know you
know
uh
scorn them for their defects for which
they are responsible and tear down the
statues
or not leave the statues well you leave
the plinth i think you have to
first destroy all the elk is what i was
just going to say first you go after the
racist elk and then and then you go from
there but i mean i think
i guess i'd like
i haven't yet heard an answer to
do you treat artists and scientists
differently in this regard is is there
is there a sufficient difference so then
the subtext of the question is how i'll
rephrase it which is cheating a little
bit because i'm sort of providing what i
think is
the reason that you might say yes it's
different
are there
sufficient differences in what art is
understood to be
from what science is understood to be
such that yes it
does make sense it is coherent and not
hypocritical to have in a single world
view
that for instance you might say
actually for an artist i want to know
something about who that person is in
order to help me assess the art but for
a scientist it doesn't matter
um yeah i think
the reason to separate these things
formally
is that science in order if we regard
something as true if we are correct in
regarding something scientific it's true
it by definition has to stand on its own
merits irrespective of where it came
from or how it emerged even you know if
a computer
mind you they're not up to it but if a
computer was capable of generating an
insight that was then borne out
by empirical tests then the point is
well what do we do with the fact that it
was a you know a mindless computer the
answer is doesn't matter what it found
is true and in fact whereas
michelangelo's david
as viewed by a highly intelligent
conscious life form from another planet
uh would presumably not be beautiful
there might there might be an ability to
assess the skill
but the form the human form that is
reflected there
has a beauty that is going to be
intrinsic to the human aesthetic well
that's true but what i thought you were
going to say was
that computers are now
perfectly capable at doing something
like looking at hundreds of thousands of
faces and making up new faces that are
perfectly plausible that don't exist
right so it's basically a big data
version of creativity you know an artist
who could in who could create the face
of a character and have it be perfectly
realistic um without that person ever
having existed that's somebody who has
terrific skill a computer can do it um
through uh brute force calculation and
so
um
it you know it is not beautiful in that
sense it is
it is just extrapolating
um whereas so i guess the point is a
computer you know you could also
obviously teach a computer to generate
statues using uh
cnc machines and those statues might
beautifully in some sense render the
human form but that's not art in the
same way that michelangelo's david
uh is art because it took
you know to render something
like flesh in stone takes tremendous
insight about both flesh and stone at
the very least so i wasn't sure why you
were talking about computers it seems
irrelevant to the conversation we're
having but just then
i feel like what you arrived at
potentially
the conclusion that that could emerge
from what you just arrived at is
computers
will be able to do successful science
before computers can make successful art
that art
art by its
i was going to say something that
kind of i don't know art
has more of the humanity in it that it
cannot be separated from it and science
while deeply creative while the
hypothesis
generation and the understanding the
predictions that follow and the
experimental design and the
interpretation of the results all of
these are better done by humans still
but the but
because it is more of a process at least
once you have the hypothesis
it is potentially better
more capably done by a computer than
art might be well
this is i feel like this is the
conclusion that was opened up by what by
your
going off on computers there ish i would
argue that in order to be art it has to
not be done by a computer now maybe if
they're eventually essentially in
computers
that will be different but uh doing this
through brute force calculation is
specifically invalidating the uh
the artistic capacity
but i will point out that there are some
uncomfortable
places in science that we already see
this
and i can name two and probably given
time i could come up with some more but
one is the protein folding
issue in which a computer has recently
basically
outstripped human capacity to predict
functionality from fold approximately
so the the this here is
we
humans have understood enough about a
situation and see that there are so many
variations possible that we
we are better off outsourcing the check
all the possibilities to a computer is
is that what
is here it's it's a little more
interesting than that right the computer
actually successfully
inferred
i i don't want to say more than i
understand here i haven't looked at it
recently and this isn't my field in the
first place but
figuring out how to fold something so
that it does a particular job or how to
infer the job that it does by how it's
you know the sequence from
how will it fold from the sequence that
you the linear sequence that you've
written etc that's a very difficult set
of puzzles and anyway some uh
system has recently demonstrated
superior capacity here so it's more
complicated than for instance
what
what the
heuristics do
when running through
many but not all of the possibilities of
the possible phylogenetic trees
systematic analysis i was going to go to
an adjacent area here where
uh
for the sake of our audience it used to
be so in order to figure out what
if you want to understand how evolution
works you need a tree that describes how
creatures are related to each other so
that you can see
when it is that selection has built
something more than once and when it is
that it has simply propagated
something that it created once through a
series of descendant lineages so you
need that you need that phylogenetic
tree how you get the tree
involves looking at creatures
figuring out what characteristics they
have and then
asking what is the tree on which the
number of events that is the creation of
something new or the deletion of
something that already existed what is
the minimum number of those that you can
make by rearranging the tree and
basically that implies that tree's
reality in terms of closeness of
relationship this wants more explanation
but you've got taxa you've got
characters that those taxa have
how do you arrange how do you imagine
the attacks that are related to one
another which requires the fewest number
of evolutionary transitions to have gone
right the fewest number of things to
have happened which then occam's razor
wise implies it is the most parsimonious
explanation but here's where this gets
interesting and relevant
it used to be
the people that we knew in this had come
from an era
in which this was done
by
brilliant
morphologists
who
very carefully looked at specimens at a
very fine level of detail in order to
figure out what their characteristics
were and this involved an incredible
kind of understanding because they would
have to figure out
when you know that the
joke was they're looking at a bump on a
bone
right when
are two bumps on two bones in two
different species the same bump
and when are they different and
sometimes you have to go into the
embryology in order to figure out
whether or not it emerges from the same
tissue bones are easy compared to soft
tissue right so the point is there were
all of these brilliant morphologists
doing the work of figuring out what the
characteristics were that allowed you to
make these trees then what happens
the discovery of
genetic sequences
now you've got this interesting
phenomenon where all of these people who
learned this brilliant
mechanism for sorting characteristics
are being overwhelmed by increasingly
the fact that you can just
put some tissue into a process that gets
the dna sequence and you have more data
it's low quality because there are only
four letters and so you can very easily
get the same letter in the same spot
from two different events but the amount
of data is so large that it overwhelms
all of the noise and so you've got all
these people who learned how to do this
in this very very difficult way that
caused them to be
intimately familiar with their study
organisms being replaced by a bunch of
people who might not recognize their
organism if they encountered in the wild
right because all they're looking at is
tissue and genes
and the point is there's really no
arguing with the fact that ultimately
the amount of data in the genomes is
going to overwhelm the morphology and
if you sequence all this stuff
ultimately it's going to give you really
really good trees if you do the
job of figuring out how to interpret the
data correctly but it's mindless so it
isn't exactly a computer doing it but it
might as well be it's machines doing
what people used to do looking through
microscopes and um and the point is uh
yeah it's
scientifically very very useful because
it generates trees that are better and
it generates them faster and it
generates them for taxa that maybe
nobody knows anything about
so you can certainly employ it in places
that you can't do a morphological or
behavioral data set right but the point
is
uh i'm going to offend a lot of people
you're already you're right there i was
thinking okay
you know it's you know already we have
occasionally gone after the ecologist
but now the systematist too well i'm not
going after them but the point is it's
not ad you know i'm not saying that look
there is admirable work but the the once
admirable work of knowing the organisms
really really well that you could look
at their structure you could look at
their embryology and you could deduce
important things about what had happened
in a long lost evolutionary story right
that work has been replaced by something
uninteresting
emergence being real
uh but leaving vague exactly
to what degree it manifests and what
that means
really what you want to see is
morphologists still doing what
morphologists do and developmental
biologists still doing what they do and
and to some degree behaviorists as well
along with the
molecular people and then comparing the
results comparing the trees that are
generated
by the molecular set to the behavioral
data set to the morphological data set
to the developmental data set and seeing
whether consistent and whether or not
and you know their end is going to be an
interesting story yes except that of
course the way uh science is funded
people are going to look at this they're
going to say well you know i could
throw x amount of dollars at some
machinery and we could get a huge amount
of data out of it or i could send you on
little trips to far flung corners of the
world to capture rare creatures where
you might learn things that you didn't
plan to learn and where's the grant
money for us in that right exactly and
so yeah you can see that what ought to
happen as a result of this huge influx
of information phytogenetic information
is that we ought to have a flurry of
insight and instead we're gonna get
mind-numbing bureaucracy and machines
humming and the biologists won't know
anything about creatures
pretty much yeah yeah okay well i did
not see us getting there but yeah that's
that's yeah we are um we are again
working without annette because once
again she has not shown up to work she's
in a box somewhere i'm sure
that sounds bad it doesn't sound bad but
i'm sure we packed it we didn't leave
her behind that's true yeah okay um
i mean
none of that was planned nope there's um
there's a number of things we could talk
about there's two things that i
definitely want to say a little bit
about oh and then we have the discord
questions there's like three things here
all right um
let's start
zachary
start
now we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
go pretty briefly through through these
these next three items um before you
show uh i
wondered what happened with the major
players in various
industries and social media this week
where and i was on twitter which is
always a mistake and i see this tweet
which so i can't see what you can see at
the moment and because many of you
aren't seeing anything i'm going to
speak as if i can see the screen and i'm
also going to explain what i can't see
to the people who can't see either one
so cnn tweeted
breaking news
are they even in the news business did
an
what is it like what happened what
happened
well it turns out that there was just
like a flurry
of
major institutions at a moment boy i
forgot to put down here exactly a couple
days ago
where they they just put out and that
was actually the only two word one
version i saw like a
one word description of what they see
themselves as being about or doing okay
so cnn breaking news next one
washington post
news
okay
npr
radio
potus president biden
democracy
oh
pfizer
science
whoa
wait a minute one more one more
mcdonald's clown
[Laughter]
wait
i think you reversed the last two
exactly i put them in the order i did
oh my god so i don't know how many of
these there were i saw sia i saw cnn
breaking news like what what happened
and then someone else posted i think it
was the potus democracy i was like wait
a minute something is happening so i
just went like okay other news
organizations
npr and
these
ones i came up with there's probably a
whole bunch much more but given these
again cnn breaking news wapa washington
post news npr radio radio
potus democracy this week
pfizer science
mcdonald's clown and mcdonald's is the
only one of these that has pinned that
as its tweet too
that's beautiful so i i mean i don't
talk like i don't even have any
commentary here but this just really
pleased me i wanted to get in on this i
feel like
what have you done what would have what
would have your work been dark horse
yeah okay it's two words i mean we spell
it in the podcast it's one word but the
concept what does dark horse one word do
okay dark horse star course okay yeah
okay um
well oh geez
i mean
you know this is a
an opportunity just to see the uh the
myopia and the skullduggery just it's
like concentrated in a single term biden
democracy really yeah and it wasn't like
i thought i think someone had
tweeted or quote tweeted that one and i
went looking figuring it was the white
house like no it wasn't the white house
it was potus it was biden's account
potus account
that tweeted democracy
yeah that's a that's
especially in light of um
in light of this remarkable speech in
philadelphia
this week it is uh
it's stunning i think it was that day
actually i think it was the day of the
speech that all of these happened yeah
and then i mean so pfizer science
really guys are you sure you sure about
that also
i feel like i thought we'd already
established i thought we already knew
that fauci was science and foundation
science could they both be science well
we don't know how many people can be
science how many yes dudes no
i think you don't see we don't know uh
he's apparently not retiring wait i
thought he was no no he's leaving his
post oh god right exactly so maybe he's
headed for pfizer and maybe they've
acquired science so they can both wear
the crown they can just like he can
or hold the scepter or whatever it is
that you do if you're master of science
master of science yes exactly um
no he's the master of disease
um
uh anyway yes
um
should we talk a little bit about this
uh speech in philadelphia if if you like
i think there's some things that i i
want i want
on the record i don't have much i read i
read a transcript i didn't watch it i
don't like you know
obama was an amazing orator yep and uh i
didn't end up loving what he did with
the country uh but i always loved to
watch him speak
the last two presidents have been very
hard to watch talk yeah very very
difficult very difficult so i did not
watch the speech but i read a transcript
oh but that's about all i know about it
and you know i've seen the
visuals well i read a transcript i
watched clips from the speech i haven't
watched it all the way through but i i
have a
distinct impression
and i don't think i don't think it
depends having on having seen the whole
thing all the way through
it was a there was a kind of brilliance
to it
a diabolical brilliance but brilliance
and the idea was that this was
a
this was a speech
that you could read
two ways there's a very benign
interpretation of the speech
and of the setting right you could say
well that's unfortunate lighting but if
you zoomed out it was
blue and red and it was only the zoomed
in that had it
looking all
fiery right exactly i don't think that
was an accident i don't think it could
possibly have been an accident
for one thing
these people are masters of stagecraft
and the fact is a president has a given
size so the degree to which the cameras
will zoom in in order to make him
appropriate sized as the speech is
viewed and recognizable right is well
understood so everything from the
marines behind him to the isolation in
the red screen the red background that
was all intentional and then the idea
that well if you zoomed out there was
blue there too and it didn't look quite
as fascist and bloody and all of that
that that's their defense for it right
and what's more i found
the you know this image that comes from
v for vendetta
which looks like they are in
intentionally trying to evoke it i
believe they are right down to the
window with the cross in it which is
much higher in the shot with biden than
it is in the movie but nonetheless
it looks to me like this is an
intentional juxtaposition i'm not saying
that window wasn't there but i'm saying
that they found a location they came up
with a justification for the location
they created the lighting they wanted to
evoke that and this leads me to an
interpretation i haven't heard elsewhere
forgive me if it's out there and i've
missed it
there's always this uncomfortable
argument about
fascism and the right
right fascism is a
defect of the extreme right and the
right not necessarily the extreme right
but the right often grumbles and
protests right about national socialists
but were they really socialists know so
yes it was on the right right you can
get into this morass but i realized
something in watching biden
reading the speech
which is that there is
the cinquan
of fascism is this hybrid between
corporate power and governmental power
right
it is also fascism inherently about
theft
right the idea is fascists target
somebody
and justify the liquidation of their
wealth well-being whatever to generate
phony growth
for
those who are in the fascist cabal
now there's that sounds true to me but i
don't know
i won't claim to be a political
scientist or a historian enough
to say that that
it feels to me that that isn't unique to
fascism there are several
political
ways of being sure
which are predicated on
we are going to
alienate we're going to make enemies of
some piece of the population
so as to unify the rest
and uh
right i don't disagree obviously if we
are to say that fascism
uh
involves a hybrid between government and
corporate power then that obviously puts
a relatively recent start date
on when fascism is invented and the
point the my real point is
some will have heard me talk about
the idea that our that the west
is a very
powerful mechanism for generating
well-being and insight and fairness
but it is a very fragile mechanism and
the point is that when that fragile
mechanism is disturbed it defaults
into a
more robust more primitive state and so
i believe what fascism is
is it is tapping into a very ancient
mode that
pre-exists corporations and pre-exists
formalized government right a lineage
against lineage conflict mechanism in
which
the stagnation of your lineage is
jump-started by going after people who
are too vulnerable to defend themselves
so here's here's the reason that this is
important in this speech
the speech again can be interpreted two
different ways and one of them is very
benign right this is this is a
frustrated grandpa who is in charge of
the country who's telling us unifi right
the people who are against unity are the
problem oh that's interesting you just
singled out a bunch of people while you
were proclaiming unity right
what do i do with that contradiction but
here's what i'm getting at
i don't think there's anything really
left-wing about the blue team
nothing other than their rhetoric right
even to the extent that they want to do
some things that are nominally
associated with progressivism it's an
excuse right it's a lost leader that is
designed to continue the march of these
already powerful people
um and the their concentration of wealth
and power
but the point is look i do think
fascism may be more likely to emerge on
the right but i don't think it
inherently lives there
and that what we are seeing
is
at a almost overtly
fascist movement that will protest that
label but you've got i mean even this
week we saw documents emerge in which
the
executive branch was having regular
meetings about who to censor online
uh who their partners in tech should
censor online right
that is the fusion of
corporate power and government power
what's more it is an egregious violation
of our first amendment rights what's
more
in this speech
the president
uses the phrase clear and present danger
and clear and present danger
is one of these phrases it sounds like a
linguistic flourish right it sounds like
good oratory good speech making it is in
fact a term that has a
very serious legal consequence
clear and present danger is the argument
that we have the right to forgo
first amendment speech rights in certain
circumstances right so in isolating or
attempting to isolate what he calls mega
republicans from regular republicans
right and from the rest of us and to
make them the demons the
insurrectionists
those who do not respect democracy right
by doing that and then invoking the
rhetoric of clear and present danger
what he's effectively saying is yep
first amendment this is not the moment
for it this is the moment for censorship
and we are the people who are going to
do the censoring and why are we doing it
we are doing it for the good of the
nation which is the biggest bunch of
[ __ ] i've ever heard right it is
absolutely
mind-boggling that these people
right these people who i will point out
have demonized us
right demonized us for stuff we turned
out to be right about who invoked their
right to censor behind closed doors
didn't tell us what it was didn't tell
you know did not allow us to see the
evidence that was being used to make
these rulings in private to demonetize
us to go after our ability to earn these
same people right are now
brazenly in public
legal terminology for exempting
themselves from first amendment
protections as they claim to be
defending the idea that you know
free and fair elections are important
there are winners and there are losers
and it is incumbent on those of us who
have lost to just simply accept it when
they themselves don't do that right in
the last election right the prior one
they were complaining about russian
collusion and that turned out to be
[ __ ] that was just a story so the
point is you've got two sides who are
now
at least if we give them the benefit of
the doubt distrustful of the quality of
our elections and their integrity right
and for them to portray themselves as
those who accept the results of
elections and the other people are bad
because they don't accept the results of
election is just
you know it's a completely selective
uh review of history so
my only point is
i think we need to take very seriously
the fact that not only
is there the evidence that these people
have
fascist inclinations i'm not saying they
alone have fascist inclinations there
are fascist inclinations on the other
side too but they are
now actively playing with the symbolism
right that blood red background right
the you know the the ranting demagogue
what does it allude to it alludes to v
for vendetta which is a movie adored by
the left and i think the key thing the
message here
is
this is your fascism right this is a
fascism of the left and the people we
are going to go after are your enemies
so don't worry about the fact that we
are going to suspend all kinds of rights
because you're going to come out ahead
right and i think that this could not
possibly be more dangerous
right these people
um have demonstrated a complete
indifference to
human suffering
and human
the loss of human life and to have them
intentionally playing with these symbols
and modes
is uh that's nature's way of telling you
where you are in history and we damn
well better listen
excellent
just one thing to add
it triggers
the sa it's the same kind of trick
rather
as
what you need privacy for if you've got
nothing to hide
what are you so worried about this for
we're going after the people that we all
know are bad
yep what do you need your rights for
you can count on us to protect you
right and and you know it's it's this
dumb little trick it's like well you
know just check if you're in the
category of the people that we're about
to go after if you're not don't worry
and join us and it's like no the the
west is absolutely dependent on the idea
that we agree on the project more than
we
support our team
right
that's it right there that's it
and you know i have to tell you
the i think the big obstacle here is
that anybody who
hears
us or others alarmed that what we saw
was fascist symbolism is going to do
exactly what they have been primed to do
which is to say
that speech yes the lighting was
unfortunate
the camera angles were yeah they
shouldn't have had in retrospect the
marines standing behind him yeah none of
that should have happened but
right and then they're going to give the
excuse there's an archaic
there's a way still that people in
government who as you say are masters of
stagecraft they have access to all of
the best everything you know from
hollywood from everything
but they still want to be able to be
like oh gosh you know we're just we're
just government folk like we didn't are
bad we didn't know
and
i agree with you i don't think errors
that large um
will routinely get made at this level no
it's and the illusion is too direct it
we were we were meant to not be able to
look away from the comparison between
the v from v for vendetta image and this
speech and then that primes you to sound
crazy to the eye to the ears of anybody
who has the excuse making mode and again
the speech can be read two ways right
the the blue and red version of this
speech is like this is grandpa he's
frustrated right and then there's the
zoom in and it's oh my god we're
targeting
americans and we are invoking our right
to exempt ourselves from the first
amendment right it's two different
speeches took place simultaneously there
and the problem is that those who will
make excuses for this are
they've been fed the material with which
to make those excuses and it is going to
make it impossible to make the case hey
this ought to alarm everybody right i
don't care if this is your team or not
if your team is on you know is it on
this kind of uh
a trip you need to you need to reign
them in and figure out how to get them
back to reason because this is the this
is the route to a tragedy of history
so
i don't know it's it
and you know i
i also think i don't know what to make
of the
connection between this and this
dark brandon meme
you've not encountered it
so
i actually initially thought the dark
brandon thing was okay it suggested a
kind of playfulness on the blue team
that they were gonna
lean into the
i don't know what it is well you
remember the uh let's go brandon
so let's go brandon
happened
the right
adopted let's go brandon as a
effectively of an open code phrase for
[ __ ] you biden
and then the left started responding
with these kind of
comic book
uh memes in which
biden was sort of a
like a sinister powerful force right
they cartoonified him it was called dark
brandon and who did this
the left okay um why would the left make
him sinister
because in a comic book
modality the fact that he is powerful
and
you know he's not a
i've only just seen it
but the idea is that you know you don't
necessarily
hate every dark character in the comic
book you may be rooting for a certain
dark character i don't know something so
the idea is you've got this feeble
mentally failing guy and the left is
actually
claiming it's sort of the equivalent of
the right claiming
that uh trump is playing
four-dimensional chess right is he
really like a bumbling bombast
no he's playing four-dimensional chess
you only think he's a bumbling bombast
because he wants you to right and this
is like
right right and so this is you know is
biden really losing his marbles is he
you know
you know being heavily managed because
they can't let him off script maybe you
can just really get both of them to the
comic books
uh it's a pink floyd song that uh the
fletcher memorial home for incurable
tyrants and kings yeah yes it's that
sort of thing well anyway all right
rant over let's just say that to the
extent that there might have been uh
hope in the left being playful with
dark brandon i think that has now
become a very sinister
way of presenting this
new
demonizing of a particular
minority for the purpose of targeting
them in a
uh
fascist transition
well this is going to sound like a weird
segue but i miss pink floyd yeah that
was from the final cut that was from
their final album and uh they were they
were important yeah but that's why god
gave us radiohead
no no
really not
um okay so we're gonna
i'm just going to briefly mention this
thing that i wanted to spend a
considerable time on today and come back
to it next week which is that barbara
ehrenreich has died
i did not know that um
she was 81 she wasn't young
and
she was we talked about her actually a
year ago i went back and looked episode
95 of darkhorse which was just about
exactly a year ago
we discussed collective consciousness
which is the episode title and i read
some from her excellent 2006 book called
dancing in the book in the streets
dancing in the streets a history of
collective joy
and i wanted to read some
from
that book uh again today and i'll skip
it but i will say
um
that uh she you know she was an
incredible inspiration she's very much
on the left uh and her 2001 book nickel
and dimed is really you know is the book
that most people who know anything about
her
uh but not much more than that no uh and
it's you know her account of
which which stemmed from a conversation
she was having with the editor of
harper's in which she said i wonder you
know some some journalists should
go and see if they can actually make a
living at minimum wage and i think it
was louis latham uh the editor of harper
said yeah how about you
and so she went out and in four
successive uh periods of time for
specific places she
uh tried to make a living as a i think
it was a walmart worker and a health
aide worker and uh
and a friend of house like diner worker
waitress
and
maybe there was an assembly line i can't
remember what the fourth one was at the
moment
but truly extraordinary book
and she's also you know she
she was remarkable uh
and she actually had a phd in biology
and then became this journalist this
activist like i said very much on the
left definitely had some i think
not totally investigated
um feelings about what
what is true in politics now carried
over from sort of what was what seemed
to be true about the parties for
instance in the 80s as you know many of
us who
uh you know who came to understand the
democrats and republicans in a different
era haven't yet updated our sense of of
what the what the parties are
um and maybe maybe i'll just leave with
a quote that i found from her in an
obituary written about her uncommon
dreams and we'll come back to this we'll
come back to erin rank next week
she said i have never seen a conflict
between journalism and activism as a
journalist i search for the truth but as
a moral person i'm also obliged to do
something about it
which you know there's there's a lot of
tension there and there's a lot of
possibility for you know real and
honorable action but of course what
we're seeing now is
uh many people who claim to be doing the
jobs of journalists actually not doing
journalism at all and only doing
activism i think she actually did both i
think she actually managed both
so i have
this principle you'll probably remember
i used to
put it on the board for students
what is the relationship
between
one's science
and one's political perspective
or one's ideology let's say is probably
a better better term right and my point
was it's absurd
to think there is no relationship but it
has to be a one-way relationship yeah
and the point is your
ideology naturally flows from what you
understand about the world it cannot be
allowed to affect what you understand
about the world right in other words the
world the universe it is what it is
it is ours to understand how it
functions and then having understood how
it functions if you understand game
theory for example you may embrace the
precautionary principle right you may
be very interested in good governance
because you're concerned about
collective action problems right these
things naturally follow from your
understanding but it cannot be
that um
your political perspective causes you to
believe things about the world that is a
completely irr illegitimate relationship
and i would argue that the same
thing is described here excellent okay
so we'll come back to erin rick next
week excellent
and then we just we owe our uh
our discord people and answer to their
question for this week since we're not
doing a q a
they had asked uh so again if you want
in on
on getting a question uh asked from
discord every week join join
join one of our patreons
question i had not previously considered
the many benefits of mixed age group
play which is outlined in your book our
book on page 157 apparently
there must be a similar benefit to mixed
age or grade schooling
what subjects do you think would be
better learned in this environment
so before like
this is a topic on which we could talk
for months years decades
but i will say to start us off here and
we're not going to spend too long at it
that
school as we also uh talk about in uh in
the school chapter of hunter gatherer's
guide to the 21st century is not only a
uniquely human phenomenon but a very new
and modern phenomenon and most the vast
majority of the learning that happens
for humans is not in a school
environment school is
a place that learning can happen and
there are some things that are probably
best learned in a school environment
but most things
that you would want to learn that is not
true for and so not only is that true
but the modern instantiation of school
where you are segregated by age
is also particularly new and
uh you know just just because population
density allows for you to accumulate you
know 20 to 30 20 to 40 kids of the same
age in classrooms throughout a city um
makes it possible but that doesn't mean
it's better and so you know the trope
the true trope like of the one room
schoolhouse such as my father actually
was raised in in iowa and um
or went to school in iowa in the 40s and
early 50s
was of course more provincial there were
fewer opportunities there wasn't as much
stuff there weren't as many resources
but what you get
is
older kids can learn how to teach and by
learning how to teach you learn what you
actually do and do not know
and younger kids
can aspire to be able to do what the
older kids are as opposed to feeling
like well this is what i'm doing this is
what people of my age are expected to do
and the fact is
that outside of a very few fundamental
and mostly very early developmental
processes
the ways and the order in which we learn
things is not even set and certainly the
timing with which we learn things is not
set so the idea that and i'm just going
to make something up it's been a long
time since our kids were young enough
for this to be relevant like if you're
in second grade it must be time for
multiplication
like why like maybe you were ready for
multiplication when you were four and
maybe you're not ready for it now
because of something that happened
developmentally and it's going to be a
couple more years and instead of feeling
like therefore you're dumb
actually let it happen when it's
relevant and that's an easier thing to
accomplish in a mixed age
classroom
um
all right i would add
something
i think
part of the problem is that
for economic reasons we built classrooms
that stratify kids by age
and place teachers at the center
and
the
the problem is that this is not how we
are built to learn
at all
it is economically efficient but it is
not intellectually efficient
and
it also creates a danger of
some kind of some permutation on
reversion to the mean where if you are
grouped with kids who are your age well
what is the range of capacities in kids
your age it's narrower than the range of
capacities in kids in general narrower
in both directions and so a kid who's
truly extraordinary doesn't have any
models nearby or peers who are capable
of
uh you know
volleying with them because they're in a
room that's been stratus stratified for
people who are near them in
uh in a capacity for the purpose of
putting them in the capacity near them
in age but not necessarily well but
nearer to them they will be nearer to
them in age because they'll be at the
same you know let's say that you're a
math prodigy right and the point is
maybe you're one of these kids who could
be through you know
calculus in the sixth grade
but there's nobody around you're slowing
down because most of the math that's
around you is you know whatever sixth
grade math looks like
so anyway my point would be
probably ideal for the human mind
is
the equivalent
it's not going to be a great example but
let's say a tennis club in which you've
got the people who are picking up a
racket for the first time and you've got
the person who's going to go on and play
at wimbledon or something
and the point is wherever you are right
as you may be picking up the racket for
the first time but as you're going back
to the locker room you may stop and
watch the pro
and learn something about tennis that
then as you develop your skills of just
basic racket handling right you've got
on board some
motivation from it and some insight
about how the game is really played when
you're advanced
and
in any case i would say
the question we've been asked is what
subjects might what subjects might lend
themselves to this i guess the question
is i'm not entirely convinced that there
are subjects that don't lend themselves
to this that in effect there is no harm
that i see well
there are some things where you'd want
to put a minimum age limit on you know
if you're doing shop if you're doing
experiments you know science experiments
with caustic chemicals something like
that yeah but even that even that
i'm not saying that we should organize
the world this way because there are
downsides but from the point of view of
how do we get people to do machine shop
work
that's really creative and high quality
right i'm not sure that the people who
are just starting out getting to peer in
the window of the masters of the craft
the journeyman is
bad i'm almost sure it's just saying
that there are ages below which you
don't want kids exposed to power tools
no no well that's all
i don't think kindergartner should be in
shop
with you know with you know a table saw
that doesn't have a sauce stop on it or
something i mean i think i think that's
it it's a really obvious point i know
you don't disagree with this it doesn't
it doesn't require any well but the
thing is in order to be good at shop you
should be doing something in
kindergarten of course and so i guess
what i would say is it's impractical to
have the journeyman near the
kindergarten
but but it's all i mean it's and it's
also true that in most cultures
kids have lots more access to things
that are actually dangerous it's the
hyper novelty of the weird world the
21st century weird world
that puts you at risk of actually
killing yourself um rather than
experimenting and being like oh okay the
three-year-olds are walking around the
dirt and stumbling near the fire and
playing with knives and that's okay
because that's how you learn that's
awesome but not once you add uh you know
wall power and you know empower tools no
i'm not arguing that but i am arguing
i'm sure there is a benefit to exposing
those kids to what happens at the top
level of the discipline you're not
letting them be hands on with it but
letting them see how it is done letting
them talk to people who do it so that
they can understand how a mind that does
this well thinks about these things so
that as they're learning the basics
they've got their eye on the right thing
right just as you might as you're
picking up skiing watch the masters
on television do it and think oh what is
that but watching people at a much
higher level is different from being in
the same classroom with them
so um is so your answer here is you you
think there's basically nothing uh that
wouldn't be better learned in this
environment and maybe we should um stop
there there's a lot more to say here but
yeah that's let's put it this way i
remain to be convinced that there's a
category where there isn't at least some
substantial benefit from seeing
uh
people who've mastered something from
the very beginnings of your
uh interacting with i think um you know
certainly like foreign languages
absolutely um you know there's a way in
which especially
modern science is taught and we used to
run into this a lot when we were
professors
where it is expected is understood as
received wisdom that
in order to end up taking say molecular
biology genetics or neuro uh you need to
have taken the introductory series first
because you absolutely it's absolutely
necessary like i didn't do that because
i happened to walk through literature
and then anthropology was like oh i want
to do bio i don't have time for that i'm
going to start with neuro like that's oh
cool okay if you're driven and you have
some capacity you can do this and
frankly you're more likely to get
um you know get caught in one of the
flaming hoops they erect for you if you
have to go through all of the basically
weed weed out courses
and
and not have the really exciting
comp like beyond competent uh professors
in the more in in
the different courses but uh it is true
that
uh in
for certain things within science and
math there is a linearity there is a
actually you already need to know this
if you're gonna do this
and so you know as as will always be the
case if you're trying to sort of throw
everything everyone in this case into a
pot and say okay let's see how you can
all learn from one another and also have
the authority teaching you things that
they think you need to know
um
there will be glitches because there
will be things that the younger people
don't know and some of the older people
also but
all of the young younger people won't
know something so they just haven't had
enough time on the planet yet to have
been exposed to them so there will be
problems with that in the more
explicitly
sometimes
linear
fields like maths and sciences unlike
places like history and art and
philosophy and
philosophies may be an educators but
yeah i think that's uh that's right and
i think you're right probably
math your ability to glean what the
experts are doing is probably pretty
darn minimal yeah and so the value of
exposing you to it early is probably
lower maybe close to zero you know the
real edge of the discipline
versus you're just getting your feet wet
with your number line it's not um yeah
you know that that's potentially not so
valuable but
but as a general matter uh yeah you
should see the full range of what's
possible as you at every stage and that
you know
it may not be practical but
but useful where it can be applied
all right well i think that brings us to
the end of uh dark horse livestream over
140.
we'll be back next week
probably no q a next week but we're
gonna leave that option open uh and uh
and
we encourage you again to subscribe like
share
follow along all of that and until we
see you next
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside and resist
fascism
[Music]
you